Randall Bell's got a kind of weird job. He's an economist who specializes in damaged real estate of all kinds. And in practice what that means is that he is the guy that you call when a house becomes notorious for some reason and you have to figure out, how in the world are you going to sell it?
兰德尔·贝尔有一份相当奇怪的工作。他是一位专门处理各种受损房地产的经济学家。实际上，这意味着当一所房子因为某种原因变得臭名昭著，而你必须弄清楚该如何将其卖掉时，他就是你需要联络的人。
For instance, he's consulted in some homes where some pretty grisly murders have happened. Nicole Brown Simpson, JonBenet Ramsey, the Heaven's Gate home where 39 people committed suicide, and what he says is that it takes a little longer to sell these home. It takes a year or two. And they sell for a little bit less than they would otherwise. But really, it's not that much of a discount.
例如，他曾为一些发生过极其惨烈谋杀案的房屋提供咨询。妮可·布朗·辛普森案、琼贝妮特·拉姆齐案、39人集体自杀的“天堂之门”住宅，他说这些房子的出售时间会稍长一些，大约需要一到两年，售价也会比正常情况稍低一点。但实际上，折扣并没有那么大。
10%, 15%, 20% discount will do the job. You don't have to go really too much beyond that.
10%、15%到20%的折扣就足够了。你不需要再降价太多。
And he says it doesn't take long for the houses to be back at their full real estate value, like nothing ever happened there.
他说，这些房子不需要太久就能恢复到其全部房地产价值，就像那里从未发生过任何事情一样。
Typically, it takes three to seven years.
通常情况下，这需要三到七年的时间。
That is just shockingly fast.
那真是快得令人震惊。
Well, people move into the house, people see that life goes on. The property gets changed around, it gets lived in. For example, the Manson property where Sharon Tate was murdered and others, that property sold for full value in about 1989.
人们搬进房子里，发现生活还在继续。房产经过修整，变得适于居住。例如，莎朗·塔特等人遇害的曼森宅邸，该房产在1989年左右就以全额价值售出了。
What happens to the people who move in? I would wonder especially if a family had kids growing up in the house that was the murder house.
那些搬进去住的人会怎样呢？我特别想知道，如果一个有孩子的家庭搬进所谓的“凶宅”会发生什么。
Well, I've dealt with people who do have kids and I would not advise someone to buy one of these houses with little kids. I'm familiar with a case that I was consulted on with a really hideous murder up in New Jersey, and very smart people bought the house and they had little kids. And, at the school, the kids were teasing them and asking them questions like, is there blood on your pillow when you sleep? Birthday parties, or neighborhood get-togethers, the kids would not come inside the house. The friends would come to the doorstep and the kids would have to come out of their house to play. So they started trying to put the birthday parties in the backyard, and the kids wouldn't even come in the backyard for a birthday party. So it became so problematic that eventually the family moved.
嗯，我处理过有孩子的家庭，我不建议家里有小孩的人买这类房子。我熟悉一个案例，当时我为新泽西州发生的一起极其可怕的谋杀案提供咨询，非常聪明的买家买了那栋房子，他们有小孩。在学校里，孩子们会取笑他们，问一些诸如“你睡觉时枕头上有血吗？”之类的问题。生日派对或邻里聚会时，孩子们根本不愿进屋。朋友们会走到门口，而住在那里的孩子必须出来才能玩耍。所以他们开始尝试在后院举办生日派对，结果孩子们连后院都不愿意进。问题变得如此严重，以至于那个家庭最终搬走了。
So while the real estate market might be willing to forget a house's reputation, third graders never will.
所以，尽管房地产市场可能愿意忘记一栋房子的名声，但三年级学生永远不会。
I think you nailed it. I had an opportunity myself, personally, to buy the Heaven's Gate mansion where the 39 people killed themselves. And when I suggested it or mentioned it to my wife, she looked at me like I was the village idiot because we have four little kids.
我想你说的太对了。我本人曾有机会买下发生39人集体自杀的“天堂之门”豪宅。当我向妻子提议或提及此事时，她看我的眼神就像我是个村里的傻瓜，因为我们有四个小孩。
People never forget what happened in most of these houses, he says. They just get used to it. Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Houses of Ill Repute. All of our stories today are about houses with terrible reputations. And in every one of these stories, in every one of these houses, actually, there's a truly astonishing level of badness that kind of sneaks up on people, and then they just get used to it. You know, they get stuck there and they get used to it and they live with it.
他说，人们在大多数这类房子里永远不会忘记发生过什么，他们只是习惯了。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是公共广播国际公司分发的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是“名声狼藉的房子”。我们今天所有的故事都关于那些名声极差的房子。事实上，在每一个故事、每一栋房子里，都有着一种令人震惊的“坏”，它悄悄地潜入人们的生活，然后他们就习惯了。你知道，他们被困在那里，习惯了，并与它共存。
Our show today in three acts. Act One, It's not a Crack House, It's a Crack Home, in which we see what happens when bad houses happen to good people. Act Two, The Crisco Kid. I bet Act Two is one of these stories which has an actual moral. There's an actual moral to the story. And it's kind of a simple moral, and I don't think I'm going to spoil anything here by telling you what the moral is. The moral of that story is, kids, stay in school. Act Three, The Bully's Pulpit, in which we visit with a house, and we ask, is there any hope for this house, this house with one of the worst reputations of any house in the country? I refer to the US House of Representatives. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目分三幕。第一幕，“这不是裂缝屋，这是裂缝家”，我们来看看当坏房子遇到好人时会发生什么。第二幕，“克里斯科小子”。我敢打赌第二幕是一个有实际道德含义的故事。这有一个非常简单的道理，我想告诉你这个道理并不会破坏什么。这个故事的道理是：孩子们，留在学校读书。第三幕，“霸凌者的讲坛”，我们将走访一栋房子，并询问：这栋房子还有希望吗？这栋拥有全国最糟糕名声之一的房子？我指的是美国众议院。请继续收听。
Act One, It's Not a Crack House, It's a Crack Home. Maherin Gangat has this story.
第一幕，“这不是裂缝屋，这是裂缝家”。马赫林·甘加特带来了这个故事。
And before we start, a quick warning to sensitive listeners that the story mentions the existence of prostitution and of drug use. Here's Maherin.
在开始之前，先给敏感的听众一个简短的警告：这个故事提到了卖淫和吸毒的存在。这是马赫林带来的报道。
Originally, I was trying to do a story about drug use in Brooklyn, and I was looking for prostitutes to interview. And on Starr Street in Brooklyn, there's a notorious house, a gathering place for prostitutes and addicts. So when I saw the house I knew exactly what it was. Broken windows, missing shingles, garbage thrown all over, women heading in and out at all hours, shiny new Escalades parked in front, young men draped in gold chains. This was not just a house of ill repute, this was a full-on den of inequity. So when the front door of the house opened, the person who came out was not what I expected. An 80-year-old man with white, messy hair.
最初，我试图做一个关于布鲁克林毒品使用的报道，并寻找妓女进行采访。在布鲁克林的斯塔尔街，有一栋臭名昭著的房子，是妓女和瘾君子的聚集地。当我看到那栋房子时，我完全知道它是什么。破碎的窗户、缺失的瓦片、遍地的垃圾、昼夜出入的妇女、停在门前锃亮的新款凯雷德，以及挂着金链的年轻人。这不仅是一栋声名狼藉的房子，这简直就是一个彻头彻尾的罪恶窝点。所以当大门打开时，走出来的人并不如我所料。那是一个头发花白、凌乱的80岁老人。
I can't give you my real name. It was too atrocious. I had to Americanize it.
我不能告诉你我的真名。那太难听了。我不得不把它美式化。
What was your real name?
你原来的名字叫什么？
[? Gerlando ?] Guisseppe Amedeo. I simply read Joseph G. Amedeo. No one could pronounce it. Amedeo, a simple name. They call me Yamamoto, which is a Japanese admiral. Armadillo, which is a rodent with an outer shell. What else? Amarillo, which is a city in Texas.
[?] 杰兰多·朱塞佩·阿梅迪奥。我干脆简写成约瑟夫·G·阿梅迪奥。没人能念对它。阿梅迪奥，一个简单的名字。他们叫我山本，那是日本海军上将。犰狳，那是一种有外壳的啮齿动物。还有什么？阿马里洛，那是德克萨斯州的一个城市。
It's the summer, but Joe's wearing a grungy sweater. You could easily mistake him for a homeless person. But when he talks, he's lucid, chatty, which has the perverse effect of making everything he says seem even weirder, like when I ask him about the prostitutes who live in his house.
现在是夏天，但乔穿着一件破旧的毛衣。你很容易把他误认为是一个无家可归的人。但当他说话时，他思路清晰、健谈，这产生了一种反常的效果，让他所说的每一件事都显得更加奇怪，比如当我问他关于住在屋里的妓女时。
They offered to bring me food, but I keep telling them I'm on a special diet. They eat all kinds of oily things and things that are heavily sugared, which I will not touch. I've relaxed a little bit. I will eat some corn muffins now and cookies and Oreos. Not too many. The body tells me when I've had enough. I said, this is too sweet. I don't like it.
她们主动提出给我带食物，但我一直告诉她们我在进行特殊的饮食控制。她们吃各种油腻的和含糖量极高的东西，我是绝对不碰的。我稍微放松了一点。我现在会吃一些玉米松饼、饼干和奥利奥。不要太多。身体会告诉我什么时候吃够了。我说，这太甜了。我不喜欢。
If you don't mind my asking-- it's somewhat of a personal question--
如果不介意的话——这是一个有点私人的问题——
Quiet. Go ahead.
安静。说吧。
If you don't mind, do you take drugs?
如果不介意的话，你吸毒吗？
Absolutely not. I have diabetes, for which I take a pill, and I have hypertension, for which I take another pill. I don't like needles of any kind.
绝对不。我有糖尿病，为此我吃药，我还有高血压，为此我也吃药。我不喜欢任何形式的针头。
For three months, I kept going back to Joe's house, to try and figure out exactly how and why this courtly, 80-year-old man ending up turning his home over to prostitutes and junkies.
三个月来，我不断回到乔的房子，试图弄清楚这位礼貌的80岁老人究竟是如何以及为什么最终将自己的家交给妓女和瘾君子。
OK, this is how I came to know about the house. I was over here prostituting.
好，我是这样知道这栋房子的。我当时在那儿卖淫。
This is Sylvia.
这是西尔维娅。
And. One of the girls was like, I [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. I want somewhere to go get high because I'm the one-- so she brought me here. And after she brought me here, I kept coming back. I never stop coming back here.
而且。其中一个女孩说，我[无法辨认]。我想找个地方吸毒，因为我是那个……所以她带我来了这里。在她带我来之后，我就一直回来。我从未停止过回到这里。
Before Sylvia ended up at Joe's house back in 2001, she'd been living on the street. She said there were around seven women in Joe's house when she was there, all of them finding Johns to make money, using the money to buy drugs, bringing the drugs back to the house to get high, and hanging out. And Joe was their unlikely patron, a World War II veteran, never married, former mortuary caretaker, and lifelong rare book enthusiast.
在西尔维娅2001年最终来到乔家之前，她一直流落街头。她说当她在那儿的时候，乔家里大约有七个女人，她们都在找嫖客挣钱，用钱买毒品，然后把毒品带回屋里吸食，并待在那里。乔是她们意想不到的赞助人，一个二战退伍军人，从未结婚，前殡仪馆管理员，也是终身的珍本书籍爱好者。
The excitement of finding a rare book that you bought it for $0.25 and you sell it for $25.
找到一本你以25美分买入、却能以25美元卖出的珍本书籍的兴奋感。
What was the best deal you ever got?
你做过最划算的交易是什么？
A letter from John Foster Dulles. I bought it for $0.50 in a famous bookshop. They had it outside tucked into a book, some silly book, and that was about $60.
一封约翰·福斯特·杜勒斯的信。我是在一家著名的书店以50美分买到的。他们把它夹在外面的一本傻书里，那封信大约值60美元。
Here's how Joe ended up so far from the book business. He's lived in the Bushwick neighborhood of Brooklyn his whole life, the last 50 years in this house on Starr Street.
这就是乔为何远离书籍生意的原因。他一生都住在布鲁克林的布什维克社区，过去50年一直住在这栋斯塔尔街的房子里。
Bushwick started changing in the 1970s and '80s, back when Joe's house was still just a normal, neat, middle class home. Back then, as one hyperbole-inclined former junkie I talked to put it, over 200 different types of heroin could be bought at a corner just three blocks from Joe's house. As the neighborhood declined, people started breaking into Joe's house regularly. He'd get home from work and find his belongings rifled through. Joe didn't have much worth stealing. There's not a lot of street resale value in the letters of John Foster Dulles. But the constant break-ins unnerved him. He didn't believe the police would help, so he came up with a plan.
布什维克在70和80年代开始发生变化，那时乔的房子还是一栋普通、整洁的中产阶级住宅。当时，正如我采访过的一位爱夸张的前瘾君子所说，在离乔家三个街区的转角处就能买到200种不同类型的海洛因。随着社区衰败，人们开始定期闯入乔的房子。他下班回家，发现自己的财物被翻得乱七八糟。乔没什么值得偷的东西。约翰·福斯特·杜勒斯的信在街头上没什么转卖价值。但不断的入室盗窃让他感到不安。他不相信警察会提供帮助，于是他想出了一个计划。
I picked some girls that are always walking in front of the house that I would see. I didn't know them. And for a free pack of cigarettes every day, they would watch the building, just let me know who's coming into my house.
我挑了一些总是走在房子门前的女孩。我不认识她们。每天给她们一包免费香烟，她们就负责看守这栋建筑，只需告诉我谁进了我的房子。
His plan worked, and it continued this way for years, with Joe gradually getting to know the women outside, until one cold day.
他的计划奏效了，事情就这样持续了好几年，乔逐渐认识了外面的那些妇女，直到那个寒冷的日子。
November came along, 1995, and they say, hey, we're cold. We're cold. We're cold. Can we come in?
1995年11月到了，她们说，嘿，我们冷。我们很冷。我们很冷。我们可以进去吗？
Perhaps it was just an especially cold night. Perhaps it's because 1995 is the year Joe retired and he was spending all his time alone in his house. But for whatever reason, he let them in. And this was a pivotal decision. The women stayed upstairs that night, and he became friends with one of them. Her name is Jean, and she took care of Joe, including once when he was very ill.
也许那只是一个特别寒冷的夜晚。也许是因为1995年是乔退休的一年，他一个人待在屋里。但无论出于什么原因，他让她们进来了。这是一个关键的决定。那天晚上，女人们留在了楼上，他与其中一个成了朋友。她的名字叫简，她照顾乔，包括有一次他病得非常重时。
I had diarrhea. And I told her, I feel very sick. My legs are weak. I can't walk. I said, I soiled my pants with this diarrhea that I'm having. She says, well, if you have to do it in your pants, do it in your pants. I'll clean it. Now, what person-- I mean, isn't this something? It's a person that tells you that, not even my mother would do that maybe if I were ill as a baby. But that was impressive. And that's the first one I brought in to stay. But the drug habit was there and there's nothing I could do.
我那时拉肚子。我告诉她，我病得很重。我的腿没力气。我不能走路。我说，我因为拉肚子弄脏了裤子。她说，好吧，如果你必须拉在裤子里，那就拉吧。我会清理的。现在，什么样的人——我的意思是，这不是一件了不起的事吗？那是一个告诉你这些的人，如果我还是个婴儿生病时，甚至连我妈妈可能都做不到。但这太令人印象深刻了。那就是我带进屋里住的第一个人。但毒瘾就在那里，我对此无能为力。
Jean started to tell her friends, other prostitutes and addicts, about Joe's kindness. And some of them moved into Joe's house. And for a while, it worked really well, even for Joe. Some of the people who showed up, including the Johns, were useful.
简开始向她的朋友们，其他妓女和瘾君子，讲述乔的善良。其中一些人搬进了乔的房子。有一段时间，这确实运转得很好，甚至对乔来说也是如此。一些出现的人，包括嫖客，是有用的。
One of the girls had an attorney which helped me without charging me the fee. We had a dentist. There was another fellow there, Bill. He did repairs on the house. He can fix storm windows or anything, repair anything about the house. I was so happy I had them [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
其中一个女孩有个律师，他免费帮了我忙。我们有一个牙医。那里还有另一个人，比尔。他负责修理房子。他能修理防风窗或任何东西，修理房子里的任何东西。我很高兴我有他们[无法辨认]。
But then the house started attracting more than just lawyers and handymen. Scarier types began showing up, and more people overall. And men moved in, and people who didn't even talk to Joe. And whatever lingering normalcy was left in the house vanished. Joe became a tenant in his own house, cramped into one room on the ground floor while anywhere between half a dozen and 15 other people just took the place over.
但后来房子开始吸引的不仅仅是律师和修理工。更可怕的人开始出现，总人数也越来越多。男人搬了进来，甚至有些根本不和乔说话的人也搬了进来。房子里残留的任何常态都消失了。乔成了自己房子里的租客，挤在一楼的一个房间里，而与此同时，六到十五个其他人干脆占领了整个地方。
Joe never let me see the inside of the house. He would only talk to me outside. I think he just didn't want to see my reaction to how he was living and what his house had become. Joe's project, as he calls it, had spiraled out of control.
乔从未让我看过房子内部。他只会在外面和我谈话。我想他只是不想看到我对他的居住方式以及他的房子变成了什么样子的反应。乔的项目，正如他所称，已经失控了。
The project as it is today is a failure. The thing I started doesn't exist anymore. Now we're getting in the criminal-- the criminal set is coming here. There's a pipeline among criminals and they all find their way to this house, you see.
今天的项目是一个失败。我开始的东西已经不存在了。现在我们要进入犯罪领域了——罪犯正来到这里。罪犯之间有一条管道，他们都能找到通往这栋房子的路，你明白吗。
Do you feel a little isolated or scared inside the house?
在房子里，你会感到有点孤立或害怕吗？
It's too late to be frightened.
害怕已经太晚了。
Do you have your own room here?
你有自己的房间吗？
I had all of the rooms were mine. Now I have just a little tiny little space here. The entire upper floors were empty at that time and very neat. Today, you'll find hell. Actually, wholly hell. This is the foretaste of hell. I haven't been up there since 2002. I know what those rooms used to look like. I don't dare, I just don't want to see it. I don't want the memory picture.
我以前所有的房间都是我的。现在我只有一个很小的空间。整个楼上在当时是空的，而且非常整洁。今天，你会发现地狱。事实上，完全的地狱。这是地狱的预演。自2002年以来，我就没上过楼。我知道那些房间过去的样子。我不敢，我只是不想看。我不想要那种记忆画面。
A lot of people didn't even want to go in there. A lot of Johns didn't want to go in there. But they do.
很多人甚至不想进去。很多嫖客也不想进去。但他们还是进去了。
This is Sylvia again, describing that upper floor where Joe stopped going in 2002.
这是西尔维娅再次描述乔从2002年起就不再进入的楼上。
There was like rats moving around and the rats are almost as big as the people. I never seen a cockroach. I only see rats. There's no bathroom. I used to hold it and try to go to the restaurant on the block, but if I couldn't hold it, I couldn't hold it. But all the time I used to hold it.
那里有老鼠跑来跑去，老鼠几乎和人一样大。我从未见过蟑螂。我只看到老鼠。没有浴室。我以前总是憋着，尝试去街区的餐馆，但如果实在憋不住了，我也没办法。但我大多数时候都是憋着的。
And so, I mean, are there buckets in there?
所以，我的意思是，里面有桶吗？
Mmm-hmm. Of waste.
嗯，装排泄物的。
Besides the buckets of human waste and the rats, Sylvia said there were holes in the roof, so when it rained, it rained inside the house. There was no running water, only one room had electricity. It'd been divided up into cubicles. This is where the women slept and sometimes brought Johns.
除了装人类排泄物的桶和老鼠，西尔维娅说屋顶有洞，所以下雨时，屋里也会下雨。没有自来水，只有一间屋子有电。它被隔成了小隔间。这就是女人们睡觉的地方，有时还会带嫖客进去。
I wound up at Joe's house after I had quit working for the escort service.
我在辞掉陪护服务的工作后，落脚到了乔家。
Lisa is 27, really skinny, though she tells me her weight's not as low as it used to be. She's got sores on her lips. Even though Joe's house is a step up from the street, it's one of the last stops on a long, downhill journey for a lot of the women there. Before moving into Joe's, Lisa worked as an escort, making around $1,000 a night, she says, and moving in upscale circles.
丽莎27岁，真的很瘦，尽管她告诉我她的体重已经不像以前那么低了。她的嘴唇上有疮。尽管乔的房子比街头好一点，但对于那里的许多女人来说，这是通往漫长沉沦之路的最后几站之一。在搬进乔家之前，丽莎做陪护，她说她一晚能赚大约1000美元，出入高档圈子。
We would go everywhere, basically. There were clubs we went to. Some of them would take you out to eat. Well, I'll put it like this, I've been to the Waldorf for a few calls, and it is a big hotel. The biggest chandelier you could ever see.
我们基本上会去任何地方。我们去过一些俱乐部。其中一些人会带你出去吃饭。嗯，我这样说吧，我为了几次应召去过华尔道夫酒店，那是个大酒店。你见过的最大的吊灯。
That was two years ago. Today, Lisa says she makes a lot less, between $100 and $400 a day. Though she spends $250 a day on heroin and crack. I ask her about her relationship with Joe.
那是两年前的事了。今天，丽莎说她赚得少多了，每天在100到400美元之间。尽管她每天要花250美元在海洛因和快克上。我问她和乔的关系。
He doesn't care what we do. He just likes the fact that's there's people with him.
他不关心我们做什么。他只是喜欢有人陪着他的事实。
Does he interact with you guys a lot? Because I know he doesn't go upstairs.
他和你们交流多吗？因为我知道他不上去。
Sometimes. No, he don't come upstairs at all. He doesn't deal with what we do. He gives us our space. And he socializes. I mean, as soon as company does come, he gets lifted up. Like, when I'm around, I give him attention and affection, you know what I'm saying? Like a father to a daughter. And it lifts him up. It's like, when you give him attention, it's like he's happy that someone's talking to him. And he could talk to you for hours.
有时。不，他根本不上楼。他不参与我们做的事。他给我们空间。而且他会社交。我的意思是，一旦有客人来，他就变得兴奋起来。比如，当我在身边时，我给予他关注和情感，你懂我在说什么吗？就像父亲对待女儿一样。这让他振奋。就像，当你给予他关注时，他很高兴有人和他说话。他可以和你聊上几个小时。
So one reason Joe let his house turn into a brothel, he's lonely. And I honestly couldn't figure out the exact nature of his relationship with these women. Joe was always forthcoming with his answers, except this one. When I asked him point blank about whether he considered any of the women a girlfriend, his non-answer was revealing.
所以乔让他的房子变成妓院的一个原因，是他感到孤独。老实说，我无法弄清楚他和这些女人关系的具体性质。除了这一点，乔对我的问题总是直言不讳。当我直截了当地问他是否认为这些女人中的任何一个是女朋友时，他回避的回答说明了一切。
I can't answer that question. I can't answer that question. Sorry, I can't. It's just that I don't want to fabricate if I can avoid it.
我无法回答那个问题。我无法回答那个问题。对不起，我不能。我只是不想在能避免的情况下捏造事实。
This is how I see it. Joe's living in a house full of prostitutes, many of whom are very fond of him. I wouldn't be surprised at all if in the 10 years since the women first moved in, Joe occasionally went from the downstairs tenant to a client. Then again, the thought occurred to me, he might be gay. Joe's a lifelong bachelor who lived with his mother well into his 30s and loves rare books.
我是这样看的。乔住在一栋充满妓女的房子里，其中许多人非常喜欢他。如果在这十年来，乔偶尔从楼下的房东变成了客户，我一点也不会感到惊讶。转念一想，这个念头也闪过我脑海，他可能是同性恋。乔是个终身单身汉，和母亲住在一起直到30多岁，并且热爱珍本书籍。
But what was clear to me the longer I spent with Joe is that, even though he liked having company in his house, he felt trapped. I asked him over and over again, why don't you just call the police? How could you let this happen to your house? Joe could never answer those questions. I think there's a lot of reasons. I think part of it is that the changes happen incrementally over time. There was never one clear moment to draw the line. And partly, Joe likes having people to take care of. It's nice to still have the power to do that, especially if you're vulnerable and needy yourself.
但随着我和乔待的时间越长，我越清楚一点：尽管他喜欢家里有陪伴，但他感到被困住了。我一次又一次地问他，你为什么不直接报警？你怎么能让这种事发生在你的房子上？乔从没能回答这些问题。我想原因有很多。我想部分原因在于这些变化是随着时间推移逐渐发生的。从来没有一个明确的时刻让你画出界限。部分原因在于，乔喜欢有人让他照顾。能够做到这一点感觉很好，尤其是在你自己本身也很脆弱和需要帮助的情况下。
These are homeless people. Take them and put them in your house.
这些人是无家可归者。把他们带走，放进你的房子里。
Hi Jojo.
嗨，乔乔。
Hello. I fought with them. I didn't quite fight with them, but I spoke to the neighborhood groups. They're afraid. You have prostitutes here, and this and that, which is true. They says, we have to raise our children here. I says, well, these girls go out at 1:00, 2:00, 3:00, 4:00, 5:00 in the morning. Do your kids go out at that hour?
你好。我和他们争吵过。我并没有真的和他们打架，但我跟社区团体谈过。他们很害怕。你们这里有妓女，等等，这是事实。他们说，我们必须在这里抚养我们的孩子。我说，好吧，这些女孩在凌晨1点、2点、3点、4点、5点才出门。你们的孩子会在那个时间出去吗？
Not that Joe doesn't have problems with the things he sees the women do.
并不是说乔对他看到的那些女人的行为没有意见。
When a girl might have a needle syringe sticking out of her neck and hanging down, or another would jab her neck once and become frustrated she couldn't get the vein. She try a second time and put a second hole in her neck. I says, get away from your neck, please. Don't do that. Don't do that. Then I had to realize that one of them said, if I have $5, I'll do $5 worth of drugs. If I have $500, I would do $500 worth of drugs.
当一个女孩可能脖子上插着针筒挂在那里，或者另一个尝试扎脖子一次但因为没找到静脉感到沮丧时。她尝试第二次，在脖子上弄了第二个洞。我说，求求你离你的脖子远点。别那么做。别那么做。然后我不得不意识到其中一个说的，如果有5美元，我就吸5美元的毒。如果有500美元，我就吸500美元的毒。
In other words, they wanted this so much that it was futile for me or anyone else to try and stop it, until the girl comes to the realization, I don't want this anymore, I don't want this kind of life anymore. And some of them did that.
换句话说，她们太想要这个了，以至于我和其他人尝试阻止都是徒劳的，直到女孩自己意识到，我不想要这个了，我不想要这种生活了。她们中有些人确实做到了。
This is true. During the time I was reporting this story, Lisa quit using drugs. She said she's glad the house was there for her.
这是真的。在我报道这个故事期间，丽莎戒了毒。她说她很高兴那栋房子曾为她提供过容身之所。
Good evening, gentlemen.
晚上好，先生们。
What's up, mister? Are you the elderly man?
怎么了，先生？你是那位老先生吗？
I'm afraid I am.
恐怕我是。
It's a rainy night, around 7:00 PM, and two police officers show up at Joe's house. Joe seems calm, not surprised or worried. His house has been raided before.
那是一个下雨的夜晚，大约晚上7点，两名警官出现在乔的房子前。乔看起来很冷静，没有惊讶或担忧。他的房子以前被突袭过。
As long as somebody holds the light for you.
只要有人为你举着灯就好。
Joe struggles to unlock the gate, so one of the cops does it for him. Then we all go inside. The cops tell Joe to sit down.
乔努力打开大门，所以其中一名警察帮了他。然后我们都进去了。警察让乔坐下。
Who's up there?
谁在上面？
The man who helps me with the house. [INAUDIBLE].
帮我照看房子的那个人。[无法辨认]。
Joey, come on out for a minute.
乔伊，出来一下。
You got lights in here? You don't have any lights, do you?
你这儿有灯吗？你没有灯，对吧？
I cut them off.
我关掉了。
It turns out, this visit isn't a raid. The cops are here at the request of Adult Protective Services. It's all part of a plan by the district attorney to clean up the neighborhood. Step one, get Joe out. Step two, get the prostitutes and everyone else out. A caseworker wants to take Joe to the hospital. Joe doesn't want to go. So the caseworker has asked the cops to remove him.
原来，这次访问不是突袭。警察是应成人保护署的要求来的。这是地区检察官清理社区计划的一部分。第一步，把乔带走。第二步，把妓女和其他人都弄走。一名个案管理人员想把乔带去医院。乔不想去。所以管理人员请警察把他带走。
Joey.
乔伊。
Yes, sir.
是的，长官。
How are you, buddy?
你好吗，伙计？
Not bad.
还不错。
You feeling better? I know you had a cold last week.
你感觉好点了吗？我知道你上周感冒了。
This is Sergeant Zegilla of the 83rd Precinct. He's been at the house before. Nine cops are milling around inside Joe's house. Some go upstairs. Sergeant Zegilla stays downstairs with Joe.
这是第83分局的泽吉拉警官。他以前来过这栋房子。九名警察在乔的房子里走来走去。有些人上了楼。泽吉拉警官留在一楼陪乔。
Let me ask you a few questions.
让我问你几个问题。
I'm in my 80s.
我80多岁了。
What's your date of birth?
你的出生日期是哪天？
And if you want me to survive, then I remain here.
如果你想让我活下去，那么我就留在这里。
Joe, Joe. We're going to calm down. We're not to that point yet at all.
乔，乔。我们冷静点。我们还没到那一步。
Oh, you're not?
噢，还没到吗？
I just want to ask you a few simple questions.
我只是想问你几个简单的问题。
I am not worthy of your attention.
我不值得你关注。
Oh, you most certainly are Joe. Everybody--
噢，你绝对值得，乔。每个人——
--babies and children out there.
——外面的婴儿和孩子们。
Everybody in Bushwick's worthy of my attention. All right, Joe. You know what year it is?
布什维克的所有人都值得我关注。好了，乔。你知道现在是哪一年吗？
2006.
2006年。
There you go. You know who the president is?
这就对了。你知道总统是谁吗？
What's his name? Bush.
他叫什么名字？布什。
Sergeant Zegilla asks Joe when he last ate. Joe tells him he had turkey for lunch. He tells Sergeant Zegilla he wants to stay in the house, but I don't hear the rest of the conversation, because that's when the cops kick me out.
泽吉拉警官问乔上次吃饭是什么时候。乔告诉他午餐吃了火鸡。他告诉泽吉拉警官他想待在房子里，但我没有听到谈话的剩余部分，因为那时警察把我赶了出去。
Around 10 minutes later, Joe walks out and into a waiting ambulance. None of the women living in the house full-time are around. The next day, I visit Joe at the hospital. He's on the phone with his niece. She lives in New Jersey.
大约10分钟后，乔走出屋子，上了救护车。住在这栋房子里的全职女性都不在。第二天，我去医院看望乔。他正在和侄女通电话。她住在新泽西州。
They're just running tests right now.
他们现在只是在做检查。
Are the people nice there?
那里的人好吗？
Very. Very polite. They look like they have training.
非常好。非常有礼貌。他们看起来像是有受过训练。
They have training?
他们有受过训练？
I would say so, yes.
我会这么说，是的。
Joe gets a lot of visitors at the hospital during the 12 days he's there. People from the house, social workers, cops. Everyone has the same conversation with Joe. What's next? Where is he going to go? The city is threatening to condemn the building. One cop is particularly concerned.
在住院的12天里，乔有很多访客。房子里的人、社会工作者、警察。每个人都和乔进行着同样的对话。接下来怎么办？他要去哪里？市政府威胁要谴责并拆除这栋建筑。一名警察特别担心。
I'm just wondering what the next step is when you're released from the hospital.
我只是在想，你出院后的下一步打算是什么。
Well, that's a good question.
嗯，这是个好问题。
I read the Times Newsweekly that there's a big article in the paper about the problems over there on Starr Street. They actually mention your building.
我看了《时报周刊》，报纸上有篇大文章报道了斯塔尔街那边的问题。他们实际上提到了你的大楼。
If there's anything you can do to delay bringing the building down, because I lived there 50 years and this could be my last gasp.
如果有什么办法能推迟拆除大楼，因为我住了50年，这可能是我的最后一口气了。
I don't know about that, Joe. I'd feel a lot better if, like, at the end of this, you were somewhere where you could live without having the walls coming down around you and prostitutes shooting up. You know, I mean--
我不知道那件事，乔。如果在这之后，你能住在一个不用担心墙壁倒塌、不用担心妓女吸毒的地方，我会感觉好得多。你知道，我的意思是——
A functioning bathroom.
一个能用的浴室。
Yeah. Running water. This might help.
是的。自来水。这可能会有帮助。
The day before Thanksgiving, the city condemned the building and started to board it up. The city had been threatening Joe for years, but this time a sign on the house said, quote, "Conditions in this premises are imminently perilous to life." I went inside for a few minutes with the inspector from the Buildings Department. I'd never been upstairs before. As I headed up now, the building inspector got my attention and pointed something out.
感恩节前一天，市政府谴责并封闭了这栋建筑，开始用木板封死窗户。市政府多年来一直威胁乔，但这次房子上的告示牌写着，引用：“此场所的情况对生命构成迫在眉睫的危险。”我和建筑部的检查员进去呆了几分钟。我以前从未上过楼。当我走上去时，建筑检查员引起了我的注意，并指出了某样东西。
Sorry? Oh, he's pointing out a rat to my right. Going into Joe's room. Thanks.
抱歉？噢，他在指我右边的一只老鼠。正往乔的房间跑。谢谢。
The second story was a mess. Every inch of the floor was covered with stuff. Bikes, sheets, mattresses, dozens of buckets, and books from Joe's collections scattered everywhere, on the floors, in the halls. The Buildings Department crew was sealing up the windows with boards.
二楼是一片狼藉。地板的每一寸都被东西覆盖了。自行车、床单、床垫、几十个桶，乔收藏的书到处都是，在地板上，在走廊里。建筑部的施工人员正在用木板封住窗户。
What are you guys doing? You're clearing it out?
你们在做什么？你们在清理吗？
Yeah, we got to close and seal up the window.
是的，我们得关上并封死窗户。
So is this as bad as other houses that you've done or worse?
所以这比你们处理过的其他房子更糟还是差不多？
That's the worst one.
那是目前为止最差的一栋。
This is the worst one?
这是最差的一栋？
Yep.
是的。
I headed downstairs to Joe's room. It's the first chance I've had to look around.
我走下楼来到乔的房间。这是我第一次有机会环顾四周。
I'm just peeking my head in because I can't even step inside. What I see is packages, packages of books, just all sealed up, just ready to be mailed.
我只是探进头去，因为我甚至没法走进去。我看到的是包裹，一包包的书，全都封好了，等着被邮寄。
Oh, my God. Oh, God. Oh, God. Oh, God. Oh, God. I'm moving my feet because I know there are rats here. I can hear them and I just want to keep moving. There's a beer can on the bottom here. There's a bucket. Oh, dear God. I guess that's what Joe used.
噢，天哪。噢，上帝。噢，上帝。噢，上帝。噢，上帝。我正在挪动我的脚，因为我知道这里有老鼠。我能听到它们，我只想继续走。这里底部有一个啤酒罐。有一个桶。噢，亲爱的上帝。我想那是乔用的。
After Joe heard about the house, I visited him in the hospital. I was surprised, he looked well rested. His face had filled out. He seemed calm, resigned.
乔听说房子的事后，我去医院看他。我很惊讶，他看起来休息得很好。他的脸丰润了些。他显得很平静，甚至有些顺从。
I think it's a good thing, personally. Not good for me, but for the general welfare, I think it's good. And especially for the people who live around the area, it's a good thing.
我个人认为这是一件好事。对我来说不是，但为了公众福祉，我认为这是好事。尤其是对于生活在那个地区的人来说，这是件好事。
But as he said, not good for him. In fact, a huge loss. His friends disappeared. And he lost his home and everything inside it. The house was sealed before he could get any of his papers or books. He said he felt homeless. He said he'd probably go live with his sister and her husband in Florida, even though he hates the heat.
但正如他所说，对他来说不是。事实上，是一个巨大的损失。他的朋友们消失了。他失去了他的家和里面的一切。房子在还能取走任何文件或书籍之前就被封死了。他说他感到无家可归。他说他可能会去佛罗里达和他的妹妹及妹夫住在一起，尽管他讨厌炎热。
I should somehow go with them because they ran out of money, and the thing for me to do is go there and have my address changed to hers and give them my pension money to help along. That'd be the sensible thing to do.
我应该无论如何和他们一起去，因为他们钱花光了，我该做的事就是去那儿，把地址改为她的地址，把我的养老金给他们，帮助他们维持生计。那会是明智的做法。
The sensible thing. Sounds unappealing, doesn't it? For the last 10 years living in his house, Joe has not been doing the sensible thing. And I think he liked that. He liked that everything he was doing was unexpected for a man of his age. It made him feel young. And in a weird way, in spite of everything that went wrong in the house, I think it made him feel in control of his life.
明智的做法。听起来很不吸引人，不是吗？在过去10年住在这栋房子里时，乔一直没做明智的事。我想他喜欢那样。他喜欢他所做的一切对于他这个年纪的人来说都是意想不到的。这让他感到年轻。而且以一种奇怪的方式，尽管房子里发生了那么多乱子，我想这让他感到能够掌控自己的生活。
When I met him, one of the first things he said to me was that he had to live in the house because it was the only way to have the lifestyle he wanted. I never understood what he meant, what lifestyle he was talking about exactly, till that last visit in the hospital. Then I realized, every day he stayed in that house was one more day he wasn't in Florida, living with his sister, being a sensible retiree.
当我遇见他时，他对我说的第一件事就是他必须住在那栋房子里，因为那是拥有他想要的生活方式的唯一途径。我从未理解他指的意思，他确切谈论的是哪种生活方式，直到在医院的那次最后谈话。那时我意识到，他住在那栋房子的每一天，都是他不用待在佛罗里达、和他妹妹一起做明智退休老人的每一天。
Maherin Gangat in New York City. Well, coming up, when your starter apartment actually has a starter, and a spare tire, and a steering wheel. How could the next place you live in possibly be any worse? Well, we have answers in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
马赫林·甘加特在纽约市。好了，接下来，当你的起步公寓真的有一个起步、一个备胎和一个方向盘时。你住的下一个地方怎么可能更糟呢？我们一会儿为您揭晓，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际公司，节目继续。
Well, it's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Houses of Ill Repute. We have stories about places that are notoriously bad, and about how living in these places can actually be very different than most people assume it would be. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act two, The Crisco Kid.
好了，这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目主题是“名声狼藉的房子”。我们有一些关于那些名声极其糟糕的地方的故事，以及居住在这些地方实际上可能与大多数人预想的截然不同。我们已经来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“克里斯科小子”。
You know, when you're young and you move out of your parents' house and you're just starting out, you want to act like you're a grownup. And you know what that's supposed to look like on the surface: a job, your own place to live. And then you get those things and you have to pretend that you know what the hell you're doing, even though you really don't. This happened to lots of us this way, including David Wilcox.
你知道，当你年轻的时候，搬出父母的家，刚刚开始独立生活，你想表现得像个成年人。你知道这在表面上应该是什么样子：一份工作，你自己的住处。然后你得到了这些东西，你必须假装你知道自己在干什么，尽管你其实根本不知道。这发生在我们很多人身上，包括大卫·威尔科克斯。
A quick warning before we start this story for sensitive listeners, this act, like our first act, mentions sex and drugs.
在开始这个故事之前，给敏感的听众一个简短的警告，这一幕和第一幕一样，提到了性和毒品。
When I was in high school, I never bothered looking at different colleges. From the start of my senior year I knew where I was going, the University of Houston, because my girlfriend was there. Most alumni don't look back fondly on U of H. It's a commuter school. There's no campus life, no identity.
我在高中的时候，从没费心去考虑不同的大学。从高三开始，我就知道我要去哪儿：休斯顿大学，因为我女朋友在那儿。大多数校友回首休斯顿大学时并没有深情。那是一所通勤学校。没有校园生活，没有归属感。
If you lived in the dorms, you went home every weekend because student services shut down late Friday afternoon. But going home wasn't an option for me. My family had sold their house in the Houston suburbs a few months after I graduated and moved to Birmingham, Alabama, where my dad's company was based. The spring of my freshman year I roomed in the dorms with a guy named Bill, who was 25 and fresh out of the army. He'd shown up at my front door with nothing but a duffel bag and a double-chambered bong.
如果你住在宿舍里，你每个周末都会回家，因为学生服务部门在周五下午晚些时候就关闭了。但回家对我来说不是个选项。我家人在我毕业几个月后卖掉了休斯顿郊区的房子，搬到了我父亲公司所在的阿拉巴马州伯明翰。大一那年春天，我和一个叫比尔的家伙合住，他25岁，刚从军队出来。他出现在我家门口时，除了一个行李袋和一个双腔大烟枪，什么也没带。
Our routine was pretty simple. We'd stay up until dawn getting stoned, eating frozen chicken sandwiches out of a vending machine, and watching late night game shows. If we didn't pass out, we'd hit the cafeteria breakfast buffet as soon as it opened, then go to bed and sleep until mid-afternoon. Eventually, two of Bill's friends, who made money selling ecstasy and building lasers for raves, started sleeping on our floor two or three nights a week.
我们的生活规律很简单。我们熬到天亮，吸着大麻，吃着自动售货机里的冷冻鸡肉三明治，看着深夜的游戏节目。如果我们没昏睡过去，我们一开门就去餐厅的自助早餐区，然后上床睡觉，直到下午才醒。最终，比尔的两个朋友——靠卖摇头丸和为锐舞派对制造激光灯挣钱——每周有两三天晚上开始睡在我们地板上。
I'd stopped going to class midway through the semester and got a minimum-wage job in the receiving department of a chain bookstore. The dorm was like a squat, a hovel occupied by too many people where I didn't have to pay rent. There were no responsibilities, no chores, no pressure, but it was utterly depressing. As the months passed, I decided it was time to grow up and get out on my own, make a life for myself, though I had no idea what that might look like.
我在学期中途停止了上课，在一家连锁书店的收货部门找了一份最低工资的工作。宿舍就像个棚屋，住了太多人，我还没付租金。没有责任，没有家务，没有压力，但这真的很压抑。随着月份流逝，我决定是时候长大了，出去独立生活，为自己创造生活，尽管我根本不知道那会是什么样。
By the time summer rolled around, my parents and I were barely speaking. They were furious that I'd given up on school, and I refused to listen to anyone who thought I was making a mistake. But that was just part of it. I also didn't want to talk to them because I was afraid they were going to yell at me.
到了夏天，我和父母几乎不说话。他们很愤怒我放弃了学业，我则拒绝听取任何认为我犯了错的人的意见。但这只是其中一部分。我也不想和他们说话，因为我怕他们冲我吼。
When the dorms closed up and I moved out, I didn't even bother telling them where they could find me. But it just so happens that they knew my first residence quite well, a white Chevy Beretta my dad had given me. I showered at friends' houses and occasionally crashed on their couches. Otherwise, I curled up like a cat on piles of dirty clothes in my backseat.
当宿舍关闭我搬走时，我甚至没费心告诉他们去哪儿能找到我。但恰好他们非常了解我的第一个住所，一辆我父亲给我的白色雪佛兰伯莱塔。我在朋友家洗澡，偶尔在他们沙发上凑合一晚。否则，我就像只猫一样蜷缩在后座的一堆脏衣服上。
By early June, after being turned away by a dozen landlords, I finally found an efficiency in a two-story complex called Westmoreland Square. The property manager had no problem renting to a minor with no credit, no rental history, and no money. When I filled out my rental application, he even told me about a friend of his who could get me a half ounce of weed for $40.
到六月初，在被十几位房东拒绝后，我终于在一家名为西莫兰广场的双层公寓区找到了一间效率房。物业经理对于租给一个没有信用、没有租房记录、没有钱的未成年人一点问题都没有。当我填写租房申请时，他甚至告诉我他有个朋友能帮我以40美元买到半盎司大麻。
It took a few days for the paperwork to go through. In the meantime, my dad got word to me through my girlfriend's parents that he was coming to town on a business trip and wanted me to stop by his hotel. We met for lunch. He had a note pad in front of him with a list of things he wanted me to consider, all of them variations on two themes: what are you doing, and how do you think you're going to accomplish it? The thing is, he was so calm and so reasonable. That threw me. I didn't have a good answer, but I also didn't think he knew what he was talking about. All I could do was stammer and repeat the same thing over and over. I'm doing this because I have to.
文书工作花了几天才办好。在此期间，我父亲通过我女朋友的父母传话给我，说他要来城里出差，想让我去他的酒店坐坐。我们见了面，一起吃了午餐。他面前放着一个便签本，上面列着他想让我考虑的事情，全都是围绕两个主题：你在干什么？你打算如何达成目标？关键是，他太冷静、太理智了。这让我不知所措。我没有好的回答，但我也不认为他知道自己在说什么。我只能结结巴巴，一遍又一遍地重复同样的话。我这么做是因为我必须这样做。
I'd been unhappy at school and I didn't want to do it anymore. And I finally was in a position for the first time in my life where, if I didn't want to do something, I could just stop. I made this decision because I could.
我在学校里很不开心，我不想再那样下去了。这是我人生中第一次处于这样一种境地：如果我不想做某件事，我就能直接停下来。我做这个决定是因为我能做到。
When lunch was over, my dad told me he'd have to take the Beretta back if I wasn't going to stay in school. Do what you have to do, he told me, but I won't pay for it. Then, just as I was giving him the keys, he gave me a check for $4,000. It was more money than I'd ever seen. I'm paying you for the car, he explained. Make sure you spend it wisely.
午餐结束后，父亲告诉我，如果我不回学校，他得把伯莱塔收回去。去做你必须做的事，他告诉我，但我不会支付费用。然后，就在我把钥匙给他时，他给了我一张4000美元的支票。那是比我见过更多的钱。我是在为你买车，他解释道。确保你明智地花这笔钱。
Most of the money went toward a '67 Volkswagen, and the rest went into the $350 apartment I'd just been approved for. It had a low ceiling with exposed beams, carpeting that was old but stain-free, and a plate glass window that ran floor to ceiling in the living room. Everything seemed to work OK, except the garbage disposal. Pretty early on, I flushed some leftover spaghetti down the kitchen sink and the noodles somehow wound up in the bathtub.
大部分钱都用在了一辆67年的大众车上，剩下的钱付了我刚被批准的那间350美元的公寓的租金。它有一个带外露横梁的低天花板，地毯很旧但没有污渍，客厅里有一扇从地板一直延伸到天花板的玻璃窗。除了垃圾处理器，其他的一切似乎都运行良好。很早的时候，我把剩饭里的意大利面冲进了厨房水槽，结果面条不知怎么就到了浴缸里。
My first month in the apartment was relatively quiet. I didn't know any of my neighbors and I kept to myself. Then, one day, the starter in my car went out, and I spent the afternoon underneath it in the car port. I was trying to get a screwdriver across the solenoid when I heard a soft, cheery voice.
我在公寓的第一个月相对安静。我不认识任何邻居，也很少与人接触。然后有一天，我的车起动机坏了，我在停车位下的车底趴了一个下午。我正试着把螺丝刀接触到电磁阀时，听到一个轻柔、开朗的声音。
That your Type 3?
那是你的Type 3吗？
Vintage Volkswagens fall into four types. Mine was a square back, a Type 3. You can always tell a VW nerd by their insistence on referring to a car by its type, never its name.
经典的大众汽车分为四种类型。我的那款是Squareback，属于Type 3。你总是可以通过一个大众车迷坚持用型号而不是名字称呼车辆来辨认他们。
Yeah, I said, scooting out from under the frame. The guy introduced himself as Steve. I guessed he was in his late 30s. He'd been living in the same apartment for over a decade. We wound up spending the next couple afternoons fiddling around with my car. He was nice, kind of shy, a little mysterious. He worked from home, building some sort of toy for men out of vacuums and cylinders and selling it through classifieds and gay porn mags.
是的，我说，从车架下溜了出来。那个人介绍自己叫史蒂夫。我猜他30多岁。他在这间公寓已经住了十多年了。我们最终在接下来的几个下午都在摆弄我的车。他很好，有点害羞，有点神秘。他在家工作，用真空吸尘器和气缸制造某种男士玩具，并通过分类广告和同性恋色情杂志出售。
I think we were replacing my battery connectors when he brought up our current residence. You know about this place, right? What people call it? I had no idea what he was talking about.
我想我们当时正在更换电池接头时，他提到了我们现在的住处。你知道这个地方，对吧？人们叫它什么？我完全不知道他在说什么。
Crisco Corner, he said. Everybody calls it Crisco Corner.
克里斯科角，他说。每个人都叫它克里斯科角。
A name like Crisco Corner might speak for itself, but Steve broke it down for me anyway.
像克里斯科角这样的名字可能不言自明，但史蒂夫还是给我解释了一番。
Basically, as soon as the bars let out every night, randy gay men would start circling the complex over and over looking to pick up a resident. If they got impatient, they'd park their cars and wander through the courtyard. Anyone interested in company would just leave their front door open and these strangers would walk in and join them.
基本上，每晚酒吧一关门，好色的男同性恋者就会开始一遍又一遍地在这座公寓区绕圈，试图寻找住户。如果他们不耐烦了，他们就会停下车，在庭院里闲逛。任何有兴趣找伴的人只需把前门敞开，这些陌生人就会走进来加入他们。
Really, it's no big deal, Steve said. It's not like it used to be in the glory days, not since this new company but the security gates up. And then he paused. But, it's probably not a good idea to hang out at the pool by yourself. And you might want to lock the laundry room door behind you if it's late.
真的，这没什么大不了的，史蒂夫说。不像鼎盛时期那样了，自从这家新公司装了安全门之后。然后他停顿了一下。但是，独自在游泳池边逗留可能不是个好主意。如果很晚了，你可能得把洗衣房的门反锁好。
Suddenly, I saw everything going on around me. It was as if Steve had dropped a token in an arcade machine. The complex sprang to life. Gangs of drag queens paraded through the courtyard at all hours of the day and night. Guys in leather bondage masks grilled burgers on their front stoops. Maintenance men made service calls in short shorts and roller skates.
突然，我看到了周围发生的一切。仿佛史蒂夫在街机里投下了一个代币。公寓区活了过来。变装皇后全天候在庭院里列队游行。戴着皮革束缚面具的家伙在门口烤汉堡。维修工穿着短裤和旱冰鞋上门维修。
Still, I didn't mind calling Crisco Corner home. Sure, I got hit on. Every now and then, I'd go out on my porch to smoke a joint and some strange man passing by on the street below would ask me for the code to the security gate, so we could hang out in the pool together. But after an initial period of shock, it seemed like a perfectly normal way to live.
尽管如此，我并不介意称克里斯科角为家。当然，我也受过骚扰。每隔一段时间，我就去阳台上抽根烟，街下路过的一些陌生男人会问我安全门的密码，这样我们就可以一起去泳池玩了。但在最初的震惊期过后，这似乎成了一种完全正常的生活方式。
Every week or so, my mom called. She'd ask how work was going, how I was getting along, and I'd say fine. Things were fine for the most part. My lights had been cut off. My car kept breaking down. But I was making rent and feeding myself, if nothing else. Regardless of how bad it got, I wasn't going to ask for help. And regardless of how worried she might have been, my mom wasn't offering. She'd ask how it was going, and I'd say fine, and that would be that.
大约每周一次，我妈妈会打电话来。她会问工作怎么样，相处得如何，我会说还可以。大部分时间事情还好。我的电被断过。我的车经常坏。但我付得起房租，能养活自己，至少如此。无论变得多糟，我都不会求助。无论她可能多担心，我妈妈也没提供帮助。她问过得怎么样，我就说还可以，然后就这样了。
A couple days before Halloween, around midnight, I was sprawled out on my living room floor in my boxer shorts. The lights were out, the TV was on mute, and I was listening to a Replacements record through headphones. Alex Chilton had just queued up when I noticed the shadow of a man pass by my window. Based on the shoulder length hair, I knew who it was. A middle-aged bean pole I'd taken to calling the Nuge, though he looked nothing like Ted Nugent.
万圣节前几天，大约午夜时分，我穿着平角短裤瘫在客厅地板上。灯关着，电视静音，我戴着耳机听着Replacements的唱片。当亚历克斯·奇尔顿的曲子刚响起时，我注意到窗外有个男人的影子经过。根据那齐肩的长发，我知道那是谁。一个中年的瘦高个，我开始叫他“努杰”，尽管他看起来一点都不像泰德·纽金特。
The record played through. I flipped it over. Just as side two started, The Nuge passed by again. A few minutes later, he came back. This time, he stopped. He was facing my window, moving his head around as if a guy with a tall hat had just sat in front of him in a movie theater. I got up to see what was going on and The Nuge squatted down. Without even thinking about it, I opened the blinds to get a better look.
唱片播完了。我把它翻面。就在第二面开始时，那个努杰又经过了。几分钟后，他又回来了。这次，他停下了。他正对着我的窗户，晃动着脑袋，好像一个戴高帽子的家伙刚坐在他电影院的前面。我起身看看发生了什么，努杰蹲了下来。我想都没想，就拉开百叶窗想看得更清楚一点。
When I was a kid, there were a few things my parents taught me about taking care of myself, things I had to understand before they'd leave me alone for a night or a weekend. Basic stuff, the number for poison control, keeping doors locked, not telling anyone on the phone that I was home alone. We never went over what I was supposed to do should I discover a six-foot hippie enjoying the sight of me in my underwear way, way too much. Nor did we discuss the best emergency hotline to call should that same hippie confuse my panic with excitement, move away from the window with his pants undone, and start lightly rapping on the door.
我小时候，父母教过我一些照顾自己的事，在我晚上或周末独自在家前必须明白的事。基本的东西，毒物控制中心的号码，锁好门，不要告诉电话里任何人我独自在家。我们从未讨论过如果我发现一个六英尺高的嬉皮士在非常、非常、非常喜欢看我穿内裤的样子时我该怎么办。也没讨论过如果同一个嬉皮士把我的恐慌误认为是兴奋，裤子拉链没拉地离开窗户，并开始轻敲我的门时，我该拨打哪个紧急热线。
So I stood there, paralyzed, a shell-shocked teenager trying to figure out the best way to let a pervert know I wasn't that kind of guy. I finally did what I thought any self-respecting adult would do. I went to the kitchen, grabbed the biggest knife I could find and walked back to the window. The Nuge lurched back over into his squat just as I jerked open the blinds and pressed the blade against the glass. He immediately gave me two OK signs, zipped up his pants, and scooted away. I spent the rest of the night huddled on the couch with the knife right beside me on the arm rest. Then something really bad happened.
所以我站在那里，瘫痪了，一个深受打击的青少年，试图找出让一个色狼知道我不是那种人的最好方法。最后我做了我认为任何自尊的成年人都会做的事。我走到厨房，抓起一把我能找到最大的刀，走回窗边。我猛地拉开百叶窗并将刀刃按在玻璃上时，那个努杰立即向我做了两个OK的手势，拉上裤链，溜走了。那天晚上余下的时间，我蜷缩在沙发上，刀子就放在旁边扶手上。然后，一件真正糟糕的事情发生了。
A few weeks after my night with The Nuge, Crisco Corner was hit by a tornado. It was 8:30 in the morning, and I woke up to what sounded like a freight train roaring through my apartment. That's a cliche, I know, but it's not just how the tornado sounds, it's how it feels. Fast and ferocious and gone before you know it. You close your eyes and 10 seconds later, when you open them, you expect everything around you to be rubble.
在我与努杰那个晚上后的几周，克里斯科角遭遇了一场龙卷风。那是早上8:30，我在那种听起来像货运火车隆隆作响的声音中醒来。我知道，那是陈词滥调，但龙卷风不仅仅是那种声音，那种感觉也是如此。快、凶猛，在你反应过来之前就消失了。你闭上眼睛，10秒钟后，当你睁开眼时，你以为周围的一切都会变成瓦砾。
Amazingly, my apartment was untouched, but everything on the other side of my bedroom wall, including the apartment next door, was completely demolished. The property manager wound up moving me and my girlfriend into a two-bedroom in the courtyard. If you have any interest in seeing what it looked like, you can rent a movie called Rush that came out in the early '90s. It stars Jason Patrick and Jennifer Jason Leigh as narcs who get addicted to drugs and fall in love. There's a scene about halfway through where Patrick comes home to find Leigh crawling around frantically searching the carpet for stray dope.
令人惊奇的是，我的公寓安然无恙，但我卧室墙壁另一边的所有东西，包括隔壁公寓，全被彻底摧毁了。物业经理最终把我跟我女朋友搬到了庭院里的一套两居室。如果你有兴趣看看它看起来是什么样，你可以租一部叫《火线大行动》的电影，那是在90年代初出来的。由杰森·帕特里克和詹妮弗·杰森·李主演，讲述了染上毒瘾并坠入爱河的缉毒警察的故事。在中间有一幕，帕特里克回到家发现李疯狂地在寻找地毯上的零星毒品。
Nothing he does to get her to calm down works, so as a last resort he tosses her face down on a bed and violently sodomizes her. Let me repeat that. He violently sodomizes her so she'll calm down. That scene was filmed in my bedroom.
为了让她平静下来，他试了什么方法都没用，作为最后手段，他把她脸朝下扔在床上并粗暴地鸡奸了她。让我重复一遍。他粗暴地鸡奸了她，以便让她平静下来。那一幕就是在我卧室拍摄的。
I kept trying to tough it out at Crisco Corner, but things only got worse. The property manager was so desperate to keep the place occupied after the tornado that he gave up even pretending to screen tenants. Most of my new neighbors looked like they were hooked on drugs far more serious than anything I'd ever touched. The cops started showing up on a regular basis. And the scarier it got, the more trapped I felt.
我一直试图在克里斯科角坚持下去，但事情只会变得更糟。物业经理为了在龙卷风后保持入住率变得如此绝望，以至于他连假装筛选租户都放弃了。我大多数新邻居看起来像是染上了比我接触过的一切都要严重的毒瘾。警察开始定期出现。情况越可怕，我就越感到被困住了。
Up until all of this, the idea of living on my own had seemed liberating, fun. But I'd never realized what I was signing up for. The possibility that when something truly horrible happened, no one was going to step in and save me, that's what hit me for the first time the morning the tornado struck.
在那之前，独立生活的想法似乎是解放，是有趣的。但我从未意识到我正在签署一份什么样的契约。那是在龙卷风袭击的早晨，我第一次明白：当真正可怕的事情发生时，没人会介入救我。
I'd started looking for a pay phone so I could call my parents. At one point, I crossed under some police tape and a cop threatened to take me to jail. Telling him I was trying to get home to my apartment didn't matter. Giving him a hangdog look that said I was just a kid who needed someone, anyone, to make life a little easier didn't make a difference. To this cop, I was just another guy standing around in his pajamas, kicking shingles with his slippers, wondering where to go from here.
我开始寻找公用电话以便给父母打电话。有一次，我穿过警察的隔离带，一名警察威胁要抓我坐牢。告诉他我正试着回家去我的公寓没用。我那种眼神看起来就像个需要某人——任何人——让生活变得轻松一点的孩子，对他来说也没起到任何作用。对这个警察来说，我只是另一个穿着睡衣站在那儿、拖鞋踢着瓦片、想知道从这里该去哪儿的家伙。
I wound up calling my mom from a grocery store a mile away. The conversation was short and matter of fact. But if there was ever a point at which I was willing to admit that I wasn't fine, that was it. She didn't ask how I was doing. For the first time in months, the only thing she asked was, what are you going to do now? I told her I didn't know. And then there was a long pause.
我最终在离那儿一英里的杂货店给我妈打了个电话。谈话简短而就事论事。但如果说有什么时刻是我愿意承认我过得并不好，那次就是。她没有问我过得怎么样。这是几个月来，她唯一问的一句话是：你现在打算做什么？我告诉她我不知道。然后是一阵长时间的沉默。
Mom, I could have died.
妈，我差点死了。
But you didn't, she said. You're OK.
但你没死，她说。你还好。
As I was getting off the phone, she told me to call if I needed anything. I hung up knowing I wouldn't. Then I went home and spent the rest of the day by the pool, staring at a dresser that had sunk to the bottom of the deep end.
挂电话时，她告诉我如果需要什么就打给她。我挂断电话，知道我不会的。然后我回到家，余下的一天都在泳池边度过，盯着一个沉在深水区底部的梳妆台。
David Wilcox in Chicago.
大卫·威尔科克斯在芝加哥。
[MUSIC - "STRANGLEHOLD" BY TED NUGENT]
[音乐 - 泰德·纽金特的《Stranglehold》]
Act Three, The Bully's Pulpit.
第三幕，“霸凌者的讲坛”。
Well, we now turn to one of the biggest houses of ill repute on the planet, the US House of Representatives. And, yes, you've heard about the corruption, you've heard about the lobbying scandals, you've heard about the notorious inability to address some of our most serious national problems. Why is it so dysfunctional?
好吧，我们现在转向这个星球上最大的声名狼藉的场所之一，美国众议院。而且，是的，你听说过腐败，听说过游说丑闻，听说过那臭名昭著的解决一些我们最严重国家问题的无能。为什么它如此功能失调？
Well, for the last few years, Democrats blamed all of this, every part of it, on the Republicans who were running the place. As the majority, the Republicans were-- it is hard to deny this. They were pretty ruthless. They kept Democratic Party voices out of the debate. They rammed legislation through. Because they could. They had the votes.
好吧，过去几年里，民主党人把这一切，每一部分，都归咎于管理这个地方的共和党人。作为多数党，共和党人是——这一点很难否认。他们非常冷酷无情。他们把民主党的声音排除在辩论之外。他们强行通过立法。因为他们能做到。他们拥有票数。
And now, of course, the tables have turned. The Democrats are the majority in the House of Representatives. And the question is, will things run any better? Will they run more fairly? Well, one of our producers, Alex Blumberg, went to DC to visit the House of Representatives to ask these questions.
而现在，当然，局面反转了。民主党人成了众议院的多数派。问题是，情况会运行得更好吗？它们会运行得更公平吗？好吧，我们的制作人之一亚历克斯·布隆伯格去了华盛顿访问众议院，询问这些问题。
A warning to sensitive listeners, he's actually going to be describing the legislative process of the United States of America.
给敏感听众一个警告，他实际上将描述美利坚合众国的立法程序。
Back when the Republicans still ran Congress this past summer, I spent several hours with Peter Defazio, a Democratic representative from Oregon. We talked mainly about how much it sucked being in the minority. The Republicans, Defazio said, would wait until the last minute to make bills available so that the minority Democrats had to vote on legislation they hadn't even had a chance to read. They'd hold meetings in the dead of night, where they'd take bills that had already been voted on and rewrite them. They wouldn't let the minority bring any of their own legislation to the floor. Even if it had broad bipartisan support, it would almost certainly pass. And the minority couldn't even offer amendments without visiting a special committee, called the Rules Committee, and getting their approval, which they almost never gave.
去年夏天，当共和党人还掌管国会时，我和俄勒冈州的民主党众议员彼得·德法齐奥一起待了几个小时。我们主要谈论了作为少数派有多糟糕。德法齐奥说，共和党人会等到最后一刻才拿出法案，这样少数派民主党人不得不对他们甚至没机会阅读的立法进行投票。他们会在深夜举行会议，在那里他们会把已经投票表决的法案拿出来重写。他们不让少数派把任何他们自己的立法带到众议院。即使它有广泛的两党支持，也几乎肯定会通过。而且少数派甚至不能提出修正案，除非访问一个特别委员会，即规则委员会，并获得他们的批准，而他们几乎从不批准。
You know, you come in and sometimes there will be a fair number of people. Other times there will just be one or two people there. And generally, the Republicans act very bored. The Democrats try and be helpful and make points about your amendment. But the Republicans just act bored. I've had the chairman of the committee turn his back on me when I was testifying just to chat with his staff, just to show his contempt and the fact that I'm insignificant. He's not going to allow my amendment. You might as well leave now.
你知道，你进来，有时会有相当多的人。其他时候只有一两个人。共和党人通常表现得非常无聊。民主党人尝试提供帮助，并就你的修正案提出观点。但共和党人只是表现得无聊。委员会主席在我作证时背对我，只是为了和他的员工聊天，只是为了显示他的蔑视以及我是多么微不足道。他不会允许我的修正案。你最好现在就离开。
Parliamentary inquiry.
议会询问。
And then, there was this trick, holding the vote open.
然后，还有这一招，保持投票开放。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] inquire.
[无法辨认]询问。
The speaker, I have a plane to catch in about one hour. Am I going to be able to do it? Will the vote be ended by that time?
发言人，我大约一小时后有飞机要赶。我能赶得上吗？到那时投票会结束吗？
Not a proper parliamentary inquiry.
这不是一个正当的议会询问。
You're listening to the House floor debate on an oil refineries bill from October of 2005. The guy saying he has a plane to catch is a Democrat. And what he's really doing is trying to get the speaker to stop holding the vote open.
你现在听的是2005年10月关于石油炼厂法案的众议院辩论。那个说要赶飞机的人是民主党人。而他真正想做的是让发言人停止保持投票开放。
See,  it's the speaker's job to ask members to cast their votes and to tally those votes up. This casting and tallying is supposed to take a couple of minutes, enough time for everyone to press their yea or nay button. But occasionally, like on this bill, all the votes will come in, the speaker will see that the legislation hasn't passed, and instead of tallying and certifying the results, he does what's called holding the vote open.
看，发言人的工作是要求议员们投票并汇总这些票数。这次投票和汇总应该花费几分钟，足够每个人按下“赞成”或“反对”按钮。但有时，就像在这项法案上，所有的票都投完了，发言人看到立法还没通过，他不是汇总和确认结果，而是做了所谓保持投票开放的事情。
He and his colleagues go around and try to convince wayward Republicans to change their votes. Frustrated Democrats, who can see on the big tally screen that they've won, have to just sit and wait. For 20 minutes, 30 minutes, 40 minutes, while the majority tries to undo their victory.
他和他的同事们四处走动，试图说服不听话的共和党人改变投票。沮丧的民主党人，在巨大的统计屏幕上可以看到他们已经赢了，却不得不坐着等待。等待20分钟、30分钟、40分钟，而多数派试图撤销他们的胜利。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] inquire.
[无法辨认]询问。
Is the discretion of the chair or the abuse of the discretion of the chair and the abuse of power subject to a vote of the House?
主席的自由裁量权或主席对自由裁量权的滥用以及权力滥用是否需经过众议院投票？
This all happened for the first time when Democrats were in power. Once, in 1987, Speaker Jim Wright kept a vote on a budget bill open for 15 minutes while one of his colleagues came back to the floor to change his vote. At the time, it almost sparked a riot among the minority Republicans. Trent Lott smacked a chair in anger so hard that he almost broke it. And then congressman Dick Cheney described it as, quote, "The most arrogant, heavy-handed abuse of power I've ever seen in the 10 years that I've been here."
这一切在民主党执政时首次发生。1987年，发言人吉姆·赖特让预算案的投票保持了15分钟开放，直到他的一位同事回到现场改变了他的投票。当时，这几乎引发了少数党共和党人之间的骚乱。特伦特·洛特愤怒地拍打椅子，以至于差点把它打碎。然后迪克·切尼议员将其描述为，引用：“我在这10年里见过最傲慢、最强横的权力滥用。”
The Republicans pulled this move repeatedly in their last couple of years in power. The most extraordinary example was in 2003, during the vote on the Medicare prescription drug benefit. Republicans held the vote open for three hours, and this was well after midnight, at the end of a long day in session.
共和党人在他们执政的最后几年里反复使用这一招。最非凡的例子是在2003年，在医疗保险处方药福利的投票期间。共和党人将投票保持了三个小时，而那是在午夜之后，漫长会议结束时。
They do these things really late, both to avoid the press, and also it's like a torture technique.
他们真的在深夜做这些事，既是为了回避媒体，也因为这就像一种拷问技术。
The whole Congress was on the floor, including Peter Defazio.
整个国会都在议会现场，包括彼得·德法齐奥。
Their own members are tired. They want to go home, and everybody wants to go home. And they figure, well, we can pressure some people when they're more tired. You know, it was pretty chaotic on their side, because they brought in some cabinet secretaries who were working out of the Republican cloak room. They were dragging people off the floor to take phone calls from George Bush and Dick Cheney. You know, it was pretty--
他们自己的议员很累。他们想回家，每个人都想回家。他们想，嗯，我们可以在他们更累时给一些人施压。你知道，在那边非常混乱，因为他们带进了一些在共和党休息室工作的内阁部长。他们把人从地板上拖走，去接乔治·布什和迪克·切尼的电话。你知道，这相当——
All while the vote is being held up?
所有这些都是在投票被搁置的同时？
Oh yeah. And on our side, we're just sitting there staring at them. And every once in a while, we'll just try and say, point of order. Point of order is the rules say no vote should be held open more than 17 minutes. What's going on? And then they overrule our point of order.
噢，是的。在我们这边，我们只是坐在那儿盯着他们看。偶尔，我们会尝试说，“程序问题”。程序问题的规则是投票不应保持开放超过17分钟。到底怎么回事？然后他们驳回了我们的程序问题。
Mr. Speaker.
发言人。
For what purpose does the gentlelady rise?
这位女士起立是为了什么目的？
Mr. Speaker, for the parliamentary inquiry.
发言人，为了议会询问。
The gentlelady may inquire.
这位女士可以询问。
Mr. Speaker, my parliamentary inquiry, is it not bringing dishonor to the House of Representatives for this body to act--
发言人，我的议会询问是，让这个机构采取行动难道不是给众议院带来耻辱吗——
Gentlelady is not stating a proper parliamentary inquiry.
这位女士没有陈述一个正当的议会询问。
This is not part of the culture of corruption of the Republican Party.
这并不是共和党腐败文化的一部分。
Does this gentlelady parliamentary inquiry?
这位女士有议会询问吗？
To dishonor the wishes of people who have spoken.
去违背人们表达的意愿。
Does the gentlelady have a parliamentary--
这位女士有议会——
I have a parliamentary inquiry. When are you going to honor--
我有一个议会询问。你什么时候打算兑现——
So we would occasionally try and do that. Or every once in a while, yeah, we would break into a chorus of shame. Because it was shameful. It was incredibly shameful.
所以我们偶尔会尝试那样做。或者每隔一段时间，是的，我们会唱起合唱：耻辱。因为这是可耻的。这是令人难以置信的可耻。
Without objection, the motion to reconsider is laid upon the table.
若无异议，重新审议的动议被搁置在桌上。
Shame. Shame. Shame. Shame. Shame. Shame.
耻辱。耻辱。耻辱。耻辱。耻辱。耻辱。
It would be different people at different times. I mean, you're sitting there. It's 5 o'clock in the morning, you've been sitting there for three hours. You know, something to do. Raise your fist and yell shame. Come on, you guys have no shame.
那会是不同时期不同的人。我的意思是，你坐在那儿。那是凌晨5点，你已经在那里坐了三个小时。你知道，找点事做。举起拳头大喊耻辱。来吧，你们这些人真不要脸。
Those Democrats that were here in '93 and '94 before the Republicans took control, they put the screws to the Republicans on a daily basis. They didn't allow for amendments on large pieces of legislation and they shut Republicans out.
那些在93年和94年共和党夺取控制权前就在这里的民主党人，他们每天都压榨共和党人。他们不允许对大型法案进行修正，并将共和党人拒之门外。
As you can imagine, Republicans disagree with Peter Defazio's assessment that their behavior is at all unusual. This is Patrick McHenry, Republican from North Carolina. He says what a lot of Republicans say. They learned everything they know about majority rule from the Democrats, who abused their Republican counterparts throughout the 40 years that they held the majority in Congress. Republican amendments were routinely denied, Republican voices barred from the debate. And that whole keeping the vote open thing? They learned that from a Democrat too, don't forget.
正如你所能想象，共和党人不同意彼得·德法齐奥关于他们的行为异常的评估。这是北卡罗来纳州的共和党人帕特里克·麦克亨利。他说了很多共和党人会说的话。他们从民主党人那里学会了关于多数裁决的一切，民主党人在国会占据多数席位的40年里虐待了他们的共和党对手。共和党人的修正案经常被拒绝，共和党人的声音被禁止参与辩论。至于保持投票开放的事？别忘了，他们也是从民主党人那里学会的。
Now, generally, a discussion about who started it never gets anywhere. Just ask the Israelis and the Palestinians, or your mom for that matter. And it can be a dispiriting exercise talking to representatives about this stuff. The tactic on both sides seems to be deflect all criticism with attacks of your own, as if this were a game, which you win by never once admitting your side might have behaved badly.
现在，通常情况下，关于“谁先开始”的讨论永远不会有结果。问问以色列人和巴勒斯坦人，或者就问你妈。和议员们谈论这些事可能是一个令人沮丧的练习。双方的策略似乎都是用你自己的攻击来转移所有的批评，好像这是一种游戏，你通过从不承认自己一方可能表现糟糕而获胜。
Patrick McHenry is particularly good at this. He's a rising star in his party, in just his second term. He's young, charming, and very good at offense. When I spoke to him, he had two of his press aides in the room, and it was clear that their strategy was to counter every question I asked about Republican strong arm tactics with an equally egregious Democratic abuse.
帕特里克·麦克亨利特别擅长这一点。他是他党内的后起之秀，刚进入第二任期。他年轻、迷人，而且非常有攻击性。当我采访他时，他的两名新闻助手也在房间里，很明显他们的策略是：用同样严重的民主党滥用权力的行为，来反击我提出的每一个关于共和党强硬战术的问题。
Why did the Republicans hold the vote open for three hours in the middle of the night? Well, Democrats, when they were in power, wouldn't even allow a motion to recommit with instructions.
为什么共和党人会在深夜把投票保持开放三个小时？嗯，民主党人在执政时，甚至不允许提出带有指导性的重申动议。
Then, of course, you don't know what a motion to recommit with instructions is. And so you have to ask and, boom, you're deflected. Or even worse, you do know what a motion to recommit is, and you say, but wait a minute, a motion to recommit is a token parliamentary procedure in which the minority offers a substitute, but which is invariably voted down since votes on parliamentary motions are generally considered to be tests of party loyalty and proceed almost always along party lines. And then you get into an argument about whether or not a motion to recommit is a meaningless formality or a cornerstone of democracy. And, boom, you're deflected even more.
然后，当然，你不知道什么是带有指导性的重申动议。所以你不得不问，然后，砰，你被转移了。或者更糟，你确实知道什么是重申动议，然后你说，但等一下，重申动议是一种象征性的议会程序，少数派在其中提供替代方案，但这总是被否决，因为议会动议的投票通常被认为是党派忠诚的测试，几乎总是沿着党派路线进行。然后你就会陷入关于重申动议是无意义的形式还是民主基石的争论，砰，你被转移得更厉害了。
At one point, after a particularly dexterous verbal parry of this kind. I saw McHenry glance over to one of his aides, who sort of closed his eyes, smiled, and gave a little fist pump, the same gesture a pitcher makes when he strikes a batter out.
在一次特别灵巧的语言交锋后。我看到麦克亨利瞥向他的一位助手，助手闭上眼睛，微笑着，做了一个小小的挥拳动作，就像投手在三振击球手时所做的那样。
But fortunately, the recent midterm elections have created a perfect laboratory for the study of majority versus minority behavior. As we all know, in 2006, the Democrats came to power, and it didn't take long for roles to reverse.
但幸运的是，最近的中期选举创造了一个研究多数派对少数派行为的完美实验室。众所周知，2006年，民主党人上台了，角色转换并没有花太久。
And so in our first 100 hours of legislation, which will begin next week, we will begin by making America safer by passing the 9/11 Commission recommendations.
所以在我们下周开始的首个100小时立法中，我们将从通过9/11委员会建议以使美国更安全开始。
This is Nancy Pelosi, the newly elected Democratic speaker of the House, of course, in early January, announcing her party's legislative agenda for its first 100 hours in power. The Democrats passed all the bills in their agenda by pretty wide margins. But in doing so, they bypassed the committee process. They waited till the last minute to make their legislation available. And they didn't allow amendments, or any input really, from the Republicans, who, by the way, had also switched roles.
这是南希·佩洛西，新当选的民主党众议院议长，当然，是在1月初宣布她党派在上台前100小时的立法议程。民主党人以相当大的优势通过了议程中的所有法案。但在这样做时，他们跳过了委员会程序。他们等到最后一刻才拿出法案。而且他们不允许修正案，或任何实质上来自共和党人的意见，而顺便提一下，共和党人也转换了角色。
Good afternoon, thank you for joining us today. A group assembled here today are leading the fight for the minority bill of rights, encouraging honest, open, and fair legislative debate.
下午好，感谢今天加入我们。今天聚集在这里的一群人正引领着为少数派权利法案而奋斗，鼓励诚实、开放和公平的立法辩论。
That's Patrick McHenry, who also made a brief appearance on TV recently at a press conference with a handful of other Republican congressmen. And he didn't deny that what he was asking for might sound familiar. Pelosi asked for the same things in a letter she sent back when she was in the minority.
那是帕特里克·麦克亨利，他最近也在电视上与几位共和党议员一起举行新闻发布会。他没有否认他所要求的东西可能听起来很耳熟。佩洛西在少数派时也寄过一封信，要求同样的东西。
The bill we offer today, the minority bill of rights, is crafted based on the exact text that then minority leader, Nancy Pelosi, submitted in 2004 to then speaker of the house Dennis Hastert.
我们今天提供的法案，少数派权利法案，是基于当时少数派领袖南希·佩洛西在2004年向当时众议院发言人丹尼斯·哈斯特特提交的完全相同的文本编写的。
The point being that if Pelosi wanted open debate and minority participation then, she had to grant it now. Although it's hard not to note that when Pelosi asked for it in 2004, she was utterly ignored by the Republican leadership. McHenry says, there's no inconsistency.
重点是如果佩洛西当时想要开放辩论和少数派参与，她现在必须允许。尽管很难不注意这一点：当佩洛西在2004年要求时，她完全被共和党领导层无视了。麦克亨利说，没有不一致。
Well, because Republicans, that wasn't a key part of our campaign, talking about openness and fairness. It was a key part of the Democrat strategy and Democrat campaign. So for them to come in on their first days in power and say, we actually are going back on our campaign pledge for openness and bipartisanship in their first hours, that is hypocrisy. That is the height of hypocrisy for them to campaign on openness, but govern in a closed fashion.
好吧，因为共和党人，谈论开放和公平不是我们竞选的关键部分。这是民主党战略和民主党竞选的关键部分。所以对他们来说，在掌权的头几天进来说，我们实际上违背了我们关于开放和两党合作的竞选承诺，那简直是虚伪。他们竞选时承诺开放，治理时却以封闭的方式，这是虚伪的极致。
It takes a lot of chutzpah to make this argument. Essentially, it's worse for the Democrats to act imperiously because they said they wouldn't, whereas the Republicans never even claimed they'd be fair. Democrats say, look, this is just for the first 100 hours. And besides, all that legislation had been debated over and over again. Here's Peter Defazio.
做出这种争论需要很大的勇气。本质上，民主党人表现得专横更糟，因为他们说过他们不会那样做，而共和党人从未声称他们会公平。民主党人说，看，这只是为了前100小时。而且，所有这些立法都已经被反复辩论过了。这是彼得·德法齐奥。
Everything we're voting on in the 100 hours, we have proposed previously, we've attempted to trigger votes on the increase in the minimum wage. We begged them. We tried parliamentary maneuvers. We tried a dozen ways to bring that bill up in the House. They know exactly what they're voting on. In fact, half the Republicans wanted to vote for it in the end. I think it's an aberration from how we will treat them consistently after we get through the first 100 hours.
我们在100小时内投票的所有东西，我们以前都提议过，我们尝试过触发关于提高最低工资的投票。我们求过他们。我们尝试过议会策略。我们尝试了十几种方法把那个法案带到众议院。他们完全知道他们在投什么。事实上，一半的共和党人最终想投赞成票。我认为这与我们在100小时后将如何始终如一地对待他们有所不同。
How do you keep, though-- how do you make sure that that actually happens? You know, because I think human nature is, well, wow, it was really easy. If we just keep limiting debate. It seems to me like there must be quite a powerful incentive as the majority to limit debate and to sort of make it easier for yourself.
你如何保持呢——你如何确保那确实会发生？你知道，因为我想人性是，哇，这太简单了。如果我们继续限制辩论。在我看来，作为多数派，限制辩论似乎有一种非常强大的动力，并且让自己更容易些。
Well, that will remain to be seen. I mean, going from this point forward. I have heard very little discussion from anybody, even the hot heads, on my side of the aisle saying, no, we should just abuse them day in, day out the way they did us, and abuse the process. Not in the caucus, not in the gym, not anywhere. I haven't heard it.
好吧，那还有待观察。我的意思是，从这一刻起向前看。我听到的讨论很少，即使是我这一派的激进分子，也没人说，不，我们应该像他们对待我们那样每天虐待他们，并滥用程序。在党团会议中没有，在健身房没有，任何地方都没有。我没听说过。
What's strange is, everyone I talked to, on both sides of the aisle, said exactly the same thing about the way things should be. One party doesn't have a lock on good ideas. Minority input almost always makes legislation better. And they both seemed upset, honestly so, when talking about their treatment as the minority. It made me realize something.
奇怪的是，我交谈过的每个人，在过道的两边，对事情应该是什么样子说的完全一样。一个党派并不能垄断好的想法。少数派的投入几乎总是使立法变得更好。而且他们在谈论作为少数派受到的待遇时，似乎都很不安，确实如此。这让我意识到了某件事。
Leaving aside the question of what shutting out the minority does to democracy, to the people in the minority, it hurts and it makes them mad.
撇开压制少数派对民主的影响不谈，对少数派的人来说，它很受伤，并使他们愤怒。
Imagine, you're being told that, though you represent nearly half the country, your vote will never count, your ideas will never be considered, no one will ever listen to you, you don't matter at all. It's an utterly demeaning feeling. And it's a feeling the Democrats felt for the last 12 years, and the Republicans felt for the 40 years before that, which partly explains why this behavior can perpetuate, even though nobody really wants it to. It's hard to let go. You may look like a majority, but you still feel like a minority.
想象一下，你被告知，尽管你代表了近一半的国家，但你的投票永远不会算数，你的想法永远不会被考虑，没人会听你的，你根本不重要。这是一种极度贬低的感觉。而这正是民主党在过去12年里感受到的，也是共和党人在之前40年感受到的，这部分解释了为什么这种行为可以延续，即使没人真正希望它发生。很难放手。你看起来可能像个多数派，但你依然感觉像个少数派。
Well, there is a lot of pent-up anger. I mean, 12 years of being abused. 12 years, or at least, I think, 8 years of having the rules chairman sneer at us and turn his back. Now he's down their whining that they're not getting open rules and all these sorts of things. There is some tendency to say, yeah, this is payback. And boy, it's tough, isn't it? So I think that actually the 100 hours could be healthy. If for the first 100 hours, we treat them somewhat the same way they treated us for 12 years, and then, after that, we restore some of what I think are proper rights and privileges to the minority. Perhaps if they take back over again, they'll be a little more respectful.
好吧，有很多压抑的愤怒。我的意思是，12年的虐待。12年，或者至少，我认为，8年被规则委员会主席嘲笑并背对着我们。现在他在下面抱怨他们没得到开放规则和所有这类事情。有一种倾向说，是的，这是报复。而且，小伙子，这很难，不是吗？所以我认为那100小时实际上可能是健康的。如果前100小时，我们对待他们的方式与他们对待我们12年的方式大致相同，然后，在那之后，我们恢复我认为的一些少数派的正当权利和特权。也许如果他们再次夺回控制权，他们会更尊重一点。
The other thing about arguments over who started it, once they get going they're hard to stop. No one knows this better than Jim Wright, the democratic speaker who held the vote open back in 1987, cracking the door that the Republicans burst through two decades later.
关于“谁先开始”的辩论，另一件事是，一旦开始就很难停止。没人比吉姆·赖特更了解这一点，那位在1987年保持投票开放的民主党发言人，打破了共和党人在二十年后冲进来的大门。
Speaking in 2004 at a ceremony in his honor, he had this to say about that day. "The bottom line is that what I'd done that day did not contribute to harmonious relations. Although the maneuvers were legal and in keeping with the rules, my mind was too determined, my attitude too insistent. I believed that I offended a number of my Republican colleagues. I won the vote, but sacrificed a more precious commodity: good will. In the end, it wasn't worth it. If that day were to do over again, I like to think I'd do it differently."
在2004年为他举行的荣誉仪式上，他在谈到那一天时这样说：“底线是，我那天所做的事并没有促进和谐的关系。虽然这些策略是合法的并符合规则，但我的头脑太坚决，我的态度太固执。我相信我冒犯了我的许多共和党同事。我赢了投票，但牺牲了一项更宝贵的商品：善意。最终，这不值得。如果那一天能重来，我想我会有不同的做法。”
Alex Blumberg.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格。
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and Tommy Andres. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
好吧，我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯和我自己制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、莎拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特经营我们的网站。赛斯·林德和汤米·安德烈斯提供了制作帮助。杰西卡·霍珀提供了音乐帮助。
Our website, where not only can you get the absolutely free podcast of our program or listen to any of our old programs online, this week on the website there is information about our upcoming six-city national tour. That's New York, LA, Minneapolis, Chicago, Boston, and Seattle. We are coming to your town if you live in one of those six cities. And we are doing our show live on stage. Live.
我们的网站，在那里你不仅可以获得我们节目绝对免费的播客，还可以上网收听我们的任何旧节目，本周在网站上有关于我们即将到来的六城市全国巡演的信息。那是纽约、洛杉矶、明尼阿波利斯、芝加哥、波士顿和西雅图。如果你住在其中一个城市，我们就要去你所在的城市。而且我们在舞台上现场表演。现场。
Now, the lineup of performers is going to vary from city to city, but they include, depending on where you are, Sarah Vowell, David Rakoff, Jonathan Goldstein, John Hodgman, Dan Savage, Alexa Junge, Mates of State, plus outtakes from our new television show. To see who is playing in your city and to find out about tickets, go to our website, www.thisamericanlife.org.
现在，表演者的阵容会根据城市而有所不同，但他们包括，取决于你在哪里，莎拉·沃威尔、大卫·拉科夫、乔纳森·戈尔茨坦、约翰·霍奇曼、丹·萨维奇、亚历克萨·琼格、Mates of State，外加我们新电视节目的删减片段。要查看谁在你的城市表演以及查找票务信息，请访问我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who called me into his office the other day with a question.
我们的WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他前几天叫我进他办公室问了一个问题。
You know about this place, right? What people call it? Crisco Corner. Everybody calls it Crisco Corner.
你知道这个地方，对吧？人们叫它什么？克里斯科角。每个人都叫它克里斯科角。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多关于这个美国生活的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。